well left-wing politicians turned out
yesterday in large numbers to support
the students who walked out of school to
join anti-gun protests New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo prostrating himself
literally before these new red guards
while joining in chants borrowed from
Latin American revolutionaries watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
that was not the CNN anchor that was his
rhythm challenge brother
buffoon senator Bernie Sanders
participated as well
by the way I'm people demanding that we
have the courage to take in on the NRA
to pass common-sense gun safety
legislation that the vast majority of
the American people want it is a
beautiful day and he's a beautiful young
people so Sanders in Como attended these
rallies but they didn't go alone
they were scored by bodyguards paid for
by you who went to protect them those
bodyguards were armed of course with
guns Cuomo's bodyguards allowed to carry
more than ten rounds in their magazines
now if you wanted to protect yourself in
the same way in New York you'd be thrown
in prison and some people of course
already have been there's no ambiguity
here in a republic and we're supposed to
live in one the rulers cannot hold
themselves to standards different from
the ruled they're not Nobles they're
citizens just like you and me
you can't surround yourself with an
armed retinue and then tell the rest of
us we don't have a right to defend
ourselves
that's worse than flying your private
jet to accept a climate change award